Piccard and his crew go undercover when
they finally reach free cloud in the
fifth episode of Star Trek Picard from
dire character fates to some surprising
nods to the Past here are all the Easter
eggs and references you missed in
Stardust City rag the fifth episode of
Star Trek Picard opens with easily the
grisliest scene in the series so far as
an export Starfleet officer has his
ocular implants removed while the scene
would be difficult to watch no matter
who it was on that operating table it
becomes even more of a gut punch when
seven of nine arrives to rescue him and
reveals that the poor guy being tortured
is in fact each chef who was first
introduced to audiences during Star Trek
Voyager six season my name was a champ
your name is Egypt I remember now
each app was one of the several young
Borg drones recovered by the Voyager
crew in the episode collective in which
the ship comes across a Borg cube manned
only by five board children who have
been cut off from the collective seven
served as a surrogate parent to each F
and the other x board children and
nurtured each F as he demonstrated an
advanced aptitude for astrophysics and
voiced a desire to eventually enter
Starfleet Academy however although an
adult each have made an appearance in
the Voyager episode shattered which
takes place in an alternate 23 94 we now
know that in the prime Star Trek
timeline each have tragically didn't
make it past 2386 although he did at
some point achieve his dream of becoming
a Starfleet officer when we finally meet
dr. Bruce Maddox in the fifth episode of
Star Trek Picard he's not looking too
great fearing for his life the
cyberneticist is hiding out on free
cloud seeking aid from a crime lord
named BJ Zell at first be jazel orders
Maddox killed but then thinks twice
about it and decides to try to find out
who he's running from thinking she might
profit from trading him to his pursuers
in her attempt to butter the traumatized
doctor up the jazel offers him a drink
of tron yya a bright yellow beverage
that she keeps in a crystal decanter
Star Trek has long been characterized by
its distinctive food and drink and
tranya
actually dates all the way back to the
earliest episodes of the original series
the beverage first appeared in the
episode the Corbeau might maneuver in
which it is offered to the crew of the
enterprise as a gesture of goodwill
arania has since popped up here and
there throughout the Star Trek universe
tote Ron yes please
home unfortunately for Maddox the drink
that was originally introduced as a way
to signify trust and friendship didn't
carry the same significance in Picard
but Jaisal used it to drug the scientist
rendering him unconscious so she could
keep him as her prisoner several times
throughout Stardust City rag characters
mentioned that export seven of nine
originated in the Delta Quadrant
relaying that information with an air of
near aw seven the export femoris Ranger
from the Delta Quadrant this is of
course a reference to the mysterious
area of the galaxy that served as the
setting for Star Trek Voyager where
seven of nine was first introduced while
Starfleet has a decent presence in the
other three quadrants of the galaxy the
Delta Quadrant is full of unknowns due
to how far removed it is from the rest
of the Federation when the Voyager first
became stranded in the Delta Quadrant
they estimated it would take them
seventy-five years to return to familiar
space while in the Delta Quadrant the
crew of Voyager encountered a number of
new alien species but the most powerful
force in the Delta Quadrant was actually
one that had been introduced much
earlier in Star Trek lore the Borg the
Borg first appearance was in Star Trek
The Next Generation Season two Episode
q.who in which the alien Cube blames the
enterprise deep into uncharted space in
this case the beta quadrant to prove to
them that they're not yet ready to
handle all the challenges of the
universe you judge yourselves against
the pitiful adversaries you've
encountered so far
the Romulans the Klingon although the
species originated in the Delta Quadrant
it was the first encounter with the
enterprise that prompted the board to
travel to Federation space with the goal
of assimilating its many planets as soon
as the laaser rena draws near to free
cloud its crew becomes inundated with
Star Trek version of pop-up ads in the
form of Holograms that aggressively
attempt to hock their wares until they
are dismissed by their targeted customer
one such ad a met Rios is for a
maintenance service called the red
bullion which promises to be able to
boost the la Serena's power conversion
efficiency up from 91 percent Rios gets
rid of the ad with a flick of his
fingers but the bullying's have a long
history in the world of Star Trek first
introduced in the next generation season
1 episode conspiracy the bullying's were
named for that episode's director cliff
bolt in that episode it is discovered
that insect-like parasites have infected
a trio of Starfleet Admiral Zander
controlling them from within despite
their normal outward appearances in
Stardust's city rag picard in the crew
of the loss arena all pretend to be
people they're not in order to
infiltrate the jazel operation 7 is also
revealed to be secretly playing a very
different game than Picard and the
others and at the end of the episode
Maddox is betrayed by Agnes a person he
loved and trusted while the red bullion
was just a silly ad it could have also
been a subtle nod to the episode's
themes of misplaced trust and deceiving
appearances or maybe it was just a silly
ad there's a lot to take in when Rios
first beings down to the neon lit
streets a free cloud in Stardust City
rag but it would be hard to miss the
prominent signage from mr. Mott scare
Emporium a recurring character on Star
Trek The Next Generation mr. Mott was a
boolean barber who worked aboard the
enterprise despite the fact that boolean
czar characteristically bald commander
riker had nothing but praise for mr.
Mott skills saying he's the best barber
in Starfleet what can you do MOT often
took it upon himself to give Picard and
other members of the Enterprise crew
unsolicited advice that went far outside
the bounds of his hairdressing expertise
and on a couple occasions he actually
played an instrumental role in their
missions in the fifth season next
generation episode unification not
provided the hair pieces that allowed
Picard and data to go undercover as
Romulans in their search for ambassador
Spock of course this seems extra
significant in Picard given its focus on
both beta and the Romulan people later
in the sixth episode starship mine
Picard actually claimed to be ma telling
a group of mercenaries who had captured
him I'm I'm the Baba in Stardust City
Rag Picard dresses up as a different
character albeit without a custom Mont
hairpiece this time to the left of the
screen when Rios beams down to free
cloud as a yellow sign advertising Dabo
tables one of the many diversions
offered to visitors of the Las Vegas
like city Dabo is a Ferengi game of
chance
similar to roulette the rules are quite
simple actually although games of davao
have been mentioned on several Star Trek
shows it was most prominently featured
on Deep Space 9 where the Dabo wheel was
a fixture in quarks bar despite the
game's simplicity it's actually
extremely difficult to win due to the
high prevalence of cheating in the game
more subtle hints of all the trickery
waiting in the episode first rule of
Dabo is watch the wheel not to guaran
speaking of quark it appears the Ferengi
barkeep has successfully franchised his
establishment in the years since he was
a main cast member on Deep Space nine
including a location on free cloud when
Rios beams down to the city and stardust
city rag a large sign advertising quarks
bar can be seen to the right of the
screen along with the slogan what is
yours is ours this is likely a riff on
the model of the pleasure planet raisa
which quark visited in the Deep Space
nine season 5 episode let he who is
without sin he was an enthusiastic
recipient of the traditional rising and
greeting which he appears to have since
appropriated for himself in a new form
all that is ours is yours Clark his name
dropped again when mr. buff tells Rios
that his references have checked out
saying mr. quark of the Ferenginar was
especially satisfied with your handling
of his trouble with the Breen when seven
of nine confronts the jazel in stardust
city rags she finally gives Picard the
full tale of what happened to each have
13 years earlier he was stationed as a
science officer aboard the USS Coleman
but was on leave from a ship in order to
help seven attempt to maintain order
among the people who had been left
behind by the Federation each app was on
a recon mission near de Manta when his
ship responded to a distress call that
turned out to be an ambush orchestrated
by the jazel and her people each app
ship the Coleman likely refers to a
character from the original series dr.
Arthur Coleman who appeared in the
series 3 episode turn about intruder in
the episode the enterprise response to a
distress call and the away team finds an
injured Janice Lester being tended by
Arthur Coleman however the distress call
turns out to be a ruse so that Lester
can switch bodies with Kirk and take
control of the enterprise each app
stationing aboard the Coleman nods to a
similar scenario playing out with him in
which he responds to a fake distress
call and is ambushed so that someone
else can take control of his body
unfortunately when in turn about
intruder the body swap is reversed and
Coleman volunteers to care for Lester
each chef meets a much darker fate in
stardust city Rag check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Trek are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]